my mother swore to her dying days that
my first words were mama dada resistor
capacitor
i don't know if they had geeks back then
but i was probably one of them
there is a resurgence the 20 and
30-somethings have discovered analog
audio and they like it
there is no question that cassettes are
making a comeback
we are in the last cassette factory in
the united states
this company duplicates audio cassettes
and loads blank audio cassettes
we're like a printing press
they send us the audio graphics that
they want they specify if they want it
in a box and we put it all together
national audio company has been around
since about 1968-69
when we first got into duplicating it
was mostly small runs the occasional
band some special order things
and then about four or five years ago
there was a sudden change
every garage band you can imagine
showed up at our doorstep
wanting cassettes
2015 was probably our biggest year
and this year is without question on
target for exceeding it
analog brings a sense of warmth that is
not present in digital
the download is so
temporary and so passing you know it's
there and it's okay you listen to it and
you enjoy it but you have nothing to go
back and look at
in fact of holding it in your hands
seems to be one of the drawing cards for
the cassette
and then for the older people would be
the nostalgia thing
i think the cassettes have made a
permanent return
shouldn't have gone away in the first
place
but they did and now they're back
my biggest concern is to pass this on to
somebody else
yes there's other people that know how
to do this
most of them are my age
so i need to teach and train younger
people
i want to see
national audio continue for as long as
there are tapes to be made
you